march has come and gone and netflix is
springing into the season with almost
40 netflix originals for april this
month you can leave the world behind
with the lost in space reboot
take an emotional ride through the
midnight streets of la with six balloons
and journey into the ancient past with
troy fall of a city
we'll also see new episodes of ongoing
talk shows like the joe mchale show
and my next guest needs no introduction
with david letterman
there's going to be something for even
the pickiest viewer on netflix this
april so let's take a look at
everything hitting the streaming service
starting with the netflix originals
amateur in amateur 14 year old tehran
forte is a natural at basketball but
skill alone won't be enough when he's
transferred to a prestigious new school
with the odds stacked against him tehran
will have to push harder than ever to
live his dream of being a basketball
star
in life there are no free throws shoot
for the hoop when amateur arrives on
april 6th
fastest car season one like it says on
the box
this upcoming series is all about
finding
[Music]
the fastest car in each episode a high
ticket supercar will race a handful of
souped-up junkers to see
whether money or hometown know-how is
better at reaching the checkered flag
described as sleeper cars in netflix
series description
these secret speedsters could be
anything from an 84 honda to a minivan
but they've all been turbocharged gas
injected
and other car phrases to match the likes
of porsches and ferraris on the tarmac
season one races onto netflix on april
6th
money heist part two if you haven't yet
tuned into money heist you don't know
what you're missing
despite its silly satirical sounding
name money heist is a legitimately
riveting crime drama about
nine thieves attempting to pull off the
world's largest heist
break into the spanish royal mint and
print off more than 2 billion euros
while the entire series aired in spain
in 2017
netflix split the season into two parts
for its u.s audience
just because they can you can catch the
second part of money heist on april 6th
orbiter 9.
this spanish sci-fi drama opens on a
young girl in an interstellar space pod
on her way to a distant planet
when her pod docks at a space station
for maintenance work
she falls in love with the tech guy one
of the first humans
she's ever met and quickly finds out
that she doesn't know the whole truth
about her perilous journey
take the ride when orbiter 9 launches on
april 6th
the fourth company this film swept
mexico's aerial awards
and was reportedly on the short list for
best foreign language film at the 89th
academy awards before it was dropped
from the list
the fourth company is based on the true
story of a prison football team
that moonlighted as a violent
enforcement gang and one of mexico's
most notorious penitentiaries to
preserve the sense of realism
the filmmakers decided to take the
production inside the actual prison
and use real inmates as extras it
doesn't get any closer to home than that
and you can experience the whole wild
story on april 6th
six balloons starring dave franco and
abby jacobson
six balloons details a harrowing night
in los angeles as a woman desperately
tries to find a detox center
for her heroin addicted brother
complicating their search is the man's
two-year-old daughter who's along for
the ride
early reviews of this south by southwest
entry have praised the film's riveting
portrayal of addiction
including the emotional addiction of a
sister who can't bring herself to break
away from the brother destroying her
life
take the ride on april 6 ram das
going home rahm das was one of the
1970's most
outspoken counterculture gurus an asset
philosopher who toured the country
giving lectures
on the nature of consciousness and life
now a little
morbidly netflix is documenting ram
das's final days with
ram das going home a conversation with
the 86 year old guru as he awaits the
end at his home in hawaii ram das going
home
will be released on april 6th troy
fall of a city it's literally the oldest
story in western literature
and we still can't get enough of the
tale of troy this netflix mini-series
focuses on the love affair between paris
and helen of troy
and the advent of the trojan war you
know everything that happened in the
brad pitt movie
but with probably a lot more drama and a
lot less neck stabbing
troy fall of a city has already
premiered on bbc one to mixed reviews
there's still plenty of time for the
series to pick up steam but
i mean you already know how it's going
to end people knew how it was going to
end
800 years ago anyway check it out on
april 6th
amo season 1 making netflix's first
filipino series
amo is a 12-part mini-series about the
philippine government's war on drug
trafficking
the limited series was created by
brillante mendoza
who previously took home the award for
best director at the 2009
khan film festival for his film quinute
amo
looks like another thrilling entry in
mendoza's filmography of gritty
hard-hitting dramas
look for it on april 9th lost in space
season one the lost in space of the 60s
is undoubtedly a classic
but man is it cheesy full of cardboard
sets and robots made from the same
plastic as hula hoops
it was still groundbreaking for its time
and the robinson family were everybody's
favorite saturday night heroes
there's no longer a will robinson i am
now a useful cog in the vast
all-powerful mechanism don't talk like
that well we'll help you
is the netflix remake going to carry the
torch and delve into
all of the insane sci-fi shenanigans and
moral conundrums that elevated the
original past its shoddy budget deprived
special effects
who knows it has cool robots and a young
hip cast
so there's that
at this point all we can do is wait
until april 13th to find out
chef's table pastry season one a
spin-off of the series
chef's table this show focuses on pastry
chefs and their culinary delights
a restaurant that only serves dessert
why not
exotic ice cream bars you bet deep fried
candy
marry me if your mouth is already
watering make a reservation for season
one of chef's table pastry on april 13th
come sunday starring chuwatel ajiafor
and jason siegel come sunday tells the
surprising true story of carlton pearson
a bishop who was literally dubbed a
heretic after he
started preaching that there was no such
thing as a fiery afterlife
should be a fun ride look for it on
april 13th
charite season one this award-winning
german historical drama centers on a
hospital in berlin in the late 1800s
the series focuses on the doctors of
charitae hospital
as they try to deal with seemingly
incurable diseases
in a rapidly changing political climate
tune in for season 1
on april 19th mercury 13.
back in the heyday of space exploration
nasa put a lot of emphasis on finding
the right astronauts to be the first
humans in space
seven men were chosen to fly for the
mercury program in the early 60s but
nasa also trained 13 women for the same
program
even though they performed just as well
in training this group
dubbed the mercury 13 never flew on a
single space mission
netflix's mercury 13 documentary looks
at those forgotten women and explores
the reasons they didn't get the
privilege of being among the first
people in space
climb aboard when the documentary
premieres on april 20th
dope season two netflix's drug war
documentary series dope
landed in december 2017 and immediately
pulled in a strong viewership
the series looks at the drug issues from
the perspectives of buyers
sellers and law enforcement whether
you're a fan of the series or just now
hearing about it
you can look forward to more of the same
stories when season 2 of dope hits the
market on
april 20th appropriately enough dude
based on writer director olivia milch's
own high school experiences
dude follows four girls in their last
few weeks of school
catherine prescott lucy hale alexandra
ship
and aquafina star and the film arrives
on netflix on april 20th
kodachrome in netflix's upcoming
kodachrome
ed harris and jason sudeikis star as a
father and son who set off on a road
trip to find the last kodachrome
processing lab
it ought to be a real nostalgia-fueled
trip into memory lane for all those
old-school photography buffs out there
look for it on april 20th the letdown
season one although it already aired in
australia in 2017
the letdown will be making its way to
american audiences this april
the comedy series focuses on audrey a
young mom trying to balance her life and
relationships without going crazy
season one lands on april 21st
psychokinesis
from yeon seong-ho director of train to
busan psychokinesis is a korean
supernatural action thriller about a man
who suddenly discovers that he has
telekinetic powers
but after using his newfound abilities
to help his daughter
he finds himself in the crosshairs of an
unexpected threat
whether you're a fan of asian thrillers
or just love a good action movie
psychokinesis looks like a film to check
out look for it on april 25th
the week of the latest product of adam
sandler's ongoing deal with netflix is
the week up
a comedy about two parents during the
week leading up to their kids getting
married
sandler stars along with chris rock i'm
just saying
ac would be great you say it and we will
turn it on
i said it get ready for all the awkward
conversations and ridiculous situations
your brain can stand
when the week of arrives on april 27th
the rachel divide you may remember
rachel dolezal from her many news
appearances in 2015
as president of the spokane branch of
the naacp
dolazal claimed to be african-american
but it turned out she was actually white
dolezal subsequently resigned from her
position and faced a media backlash
now she's entering the spotlight again
as the subject of the netflix
documentary the rachel divide
tune in for all the riveting plot twists
on april 27th
bobby kennedy for president if you've
ever been curious about 1960s politics
netflix has you covered this april it's
a statistical fact that netflix releases
54 lengthy highbrow documentaries
every day and some people find it hard
to keep up
like this idiot bobby kennedy for
president will look into senator
kennedy's 1968 presidential campaign
and its tragic end when he was
assassinated in a hotel kitchen
queue it up on april 27th three percent
season two as one of the most highly
acclaimed brazilian shows in netflix
history
three percent is definitely one of those
shows you need to watch
and with the second season due out soon
there's never been a better time to get
started
the first season set the stage for a
futuristic world where our planet is
devastated by poverty and hunger
but a lucky three percent of the
population gets the chance to live a
better life free from the struggles of
the masses
where season two will take us as
anyone's guess find out on april 27th
the new legends of monkey season one
back in the 70s there was a weird little
japanese show called monkey
it was about a magical monkey warrior
who traveled the land battling monsters
and demons
and it had the best theme song ever
[Music]
the new legends of monkey is a remake of
that old show
and it follows basically the same
premise monkey leads his band of misfit
warriors across
ancient china learning valuable lessons
while they kung fu demons
should be a good old time check it out
on april 27th
original stand-up comedy april will see
a solid collection of new stand-up
comedy routines hitting the streaming
service
french comedian fairy is showing up with
his new special
fairy is the new black on april 3rd
followed by greg davies you magnificent
beast on april 10th
and kevin james never don't give up on
april 24th
that does it for all the netflix
originals now here are all the other
films and tv shows arriving on the
streaming service in april 2018
new movies april is bringing the big
guns on the action front
along with plenty of robots sharks and
magical karate
those are 500 sunglasses mortal kombat
deep blue sea and terminator 3 rise of
the machines show up on the first
as well as bad boys and pirates of the
caribbean dead man's chest
you can also expect a whole lot of
emotional character driven dramas
such as cold mountain friday night
lights life is beautiful
and scarface all of which arrive on the
first
show
later releases in the month aren't
toning down the drama with the will
smith led
seven pounds on the 15th chasing the
dragon on the 19th
and the man who knew infinity on the
27th on the flip side
only four new comedy films are being
added in april along came polly and
jackass 2.5 for coming on the first
along with the lost boys that's a comedy
right
similarly the new documentary selection
in april will be slim pickings
on the first netflix is adding big time
an expose
on the danish architect bjarke engels
and
fish people a sweeping look at people
who spend most of their lives in the
ocean
on the fifth you can check out behind
the curtain todd recall
followed by the 2017 documentary bill
nye
science guy on the 25th for family fair
we'll be getting cats and dogs
looney tunes back in action and both
flintstones films
and those aren't even the highlights for
family movies on april 1st
that honor goes to the iron giant the
single most
emotionally scarring animated movie of
all time
also the kids are bound to love the
addition of despicable me 3 on april 5th
but the family fun has to end sometime
so after you're done crying your eyes
out at the iron giant
lighten the mood with seven or the
original cabin
fever both of those arrive on the first
alongside the 2009 cabin fever sequel
and the vampire schlockfest queen of the
damned
new television netflix truly saved the
month for its original content this
april
and as such we only have two new tv
shows premiering
throughout the month on april 2nd
lapiloto season 1 hits the airwaves and
on the 24th you can catch up on call the
midwife
series 6 christmas special 2017
which is full of the holiday cheer of
nurses midwives and
birthing babies thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too